- I've always wanted to pee standing up.
- I think this is going to be dumb.
- I'm so excited.
- Very annoying not being
able to just pee standing up
because I like efficiency.
- I've wanted this my whole life.
- If my boyfriend had to
live one day with a vagina
where he had to sit down,
he wouldn't go anywhere.
- I sort of pee standing up
because you're in a squat position
because you don't want
to touch the toilet,
but I don't need a
workout when I'm peeing.
- How many times have
I been on a road trip
where a guy friend has
like pissed in a bottle,
we have to hold it.
- Pee standing up.
Next thing you know, Lady President.
- Oh, and this is the dick.
- Where does my vagina go?
- Really marketing because this says
stand up and take control,
which is something I'll
say to myself from now on
when I stand up and pee in the shower.
- This is very like malleable.
That's strange.
- I don't want a dick,
I can tell this right now.
I don't want this.
(laughing)
- I'm going to pee with my fake dick now.
- This is going to change my life I bet.
- Hold on, I have to take everything off.
- It's just not as
instinctual as you think.
Oh my pee hole is right here.
I just don't know where
the pee hole is really.
- Guys, I can't pee.
- Heyyyyyy.
You guys I'm doing it.
- I'm gonna get it started.
- Okay, I'm not as dehydrated
as I thought I was.
- This is so gross and unnecessary.
- Oh, that's how.
- I'm just going to flush, so.
- This was f***ing great.
It really was.
- I'm disappointed in myself that I f***ed
it up so bad in the beginning,
but once I got it going, I was very happy.
- I hated it.
- I also feel like there needed to be
like an instructions manual.
- I don't feel like a man.
- I'm still confused as to why guys say
they don't need toilet
paper when they pee.
There's still a little dribble
that I had to like deal with around here.
In no way would I have been comfortable
just like tucking this back into my pants.
- I couldn't pee at first
because you're so
Pavlovianly used to sitting
when you pee.
Like when I sit, that is pee time.
So I had to sit for a second
and then stand up and pee.
- I kind of missed sitting down.
I feel like there's this
kind of peace that you have
when you're sitting down and peeing.
- Oh, I also realized I'm a little less
like upset with guys when
they pee on the toilet seat
because I realized it is actually
kind of a difficult thing.
- The pee went everywhere.
- I'm all about this.
I think it's just fantastic.
- Standing next to people,
I feel like it would be a little weird.
- We just wouldn't be able to pee.
- I could pee in a urinal, no problem.
- Why do boys do this?
- Yeah, it's hard because
I feel like I have to pee,
but I can't get it all out
because I'm being stared at.
- I feel like there's a sense
of community though right now.
- You think about girls getting to become
better friends in the bathroom,
but I think it's boys.
- They totally check each other out.
- They have to.
I'm so tempted right now.
- Stop it.
- I'm not looking, I'm just tempted.
- Becky, don't look at me.
- But I peed on myself first.
Like life, first you pee on yourself
and then you figure it out.